hey it's Anna Mac here for anime opera
and today we will be talking about the
latest crazy twists in the seven deadly
sins story but before we get into it I
want to give a huge thank you to shadow
verse for sponsoring this video
shadow verse is an anime inspired epic
fantasy card game that features
beautiful art and animation I really
enjoyed the music and excellent voice
acting both in English and in Japanese
for those of you who are weaves like me
this game has over 1 million daily
players and a vibrant fun-loving global
community and most important of all this
game has quality elf waifu's that you
can't help but love shadow verse allows
you to play the fully voiced story mode
or to battle opponents from around the
world in real-time the innovative gaming
mechanics allow you to plan and
strategize as you face off against
enemies in epic battles and the more you
win the more awesome Awards you get the
game is very generous to its players you
get 50 free card packs just for
completing the tutorial Shadow verse is
free to play on mobile and PC so
definitely check it out for yourself
link in the description there's always
something new happening with the game
and as a huge fan of one punch man I was
stoked to see that shadow versus running
a one-punch man collaboration between
May 20th and June 20th during this
collaboration he rose from one punch man
will appear as leaders in shadow verse
which is extremely cool check it out
right now it's free-to-play and a lot of
fun link in the description and of
course this video will include manga
spoilers we're dealing with the latest
developments in the story so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned after the shocking revelation
that the demon king is back and that he
is now using his younger son zelgius as
a vessel chapter three one three of the
seven deadly sins manga throws in more
surprising twists and turns as it sets
up another major showdown between
meliodas and the demon king there is
actually a lot that happened in this
chapter beyond just the demon king
plotline and we got some pretty
unexpected and crazy reveals about Eskin
or the mother of chaos and Arthur
freakin Pendragon of Camelot I just knew
that we haven't heard the last of Arthur
but let's start at the beginning
the chapter starts off with Eska noir
and Hawk rushing to Leona's to warn
everyone that the demon king is back as
king Bartra Hauser crea Mora and the
others rushed to warn and evacuate the
civilians to safety we see something
that I wasn't expecting at all ESCA nor
is greatly exhausted as a result of the
journey to the capital and he begins to
cough he calls out to my el crying if my
voice can reach you then please once
more lend me your strength before it's
too late
we then see that ESCA nor is coughing up
blood and lots of it this is a clear
indication that something is seriously
wrong with Eska nor his body appears to
be breaking down for some reason and we
can safely assume that the fact that he
gave up the power of sunshine is
directly connected to this and let's be
clear this is definitely foreshadowing
that s canora's life is likely in grave
danger and that he may actually die if
he doesn't get sunshine back I am really
concerned for s Kannur now and I am
wondering what is going to happen next
his s Canora calling out to my al to ask
mile to help the sins or is he calling
out mild to ask him to give sunshine
back to him we know that s Kannur never
wanted the power of sunshine and in his
nighttime form he often refers to the
power as a curse but what s cannot be
willing to sacrifice his own life in the
name of getting rid of sunshine for good
or would he be willing to take sunshine
back in order to save his life whenever
a character starts coughing up so much
blood in an anime or manga it is always
an indication that something is
seriously wrong but I truly hope that
this is just another troll by naka
Misuzu key and that s Connor won't
actually die before the series ends
please let me know what you guys think
about this whole s Canora scene is he
going to ask my out to give sunshine
back is he going to recover or was this
scene foreshadowing that s Kannur might
actually die let me know down in the
comments meanwhile Hawk goes to his
momma and asks her to help the sins
fight the demon king now that he has
been revived once again however mama
hawk apparently replies that she is
sleepy then hawks mama who we know is
the mother of chaos finally communicates
directly
as she says to hawk that the balance has
been utterly destroyed and soon that
king will be born Hawk screams and
confusion saying that the demon king has
already come back to life and this is no
time to be sleeping but the king that
Mama Hawk is talking about is not the
demon king as she is speaking inside her
eye we see Arthur Pendragon of Camelot
still being pierced by the legendary
sword Excalibur we've all been wondering
about Arthur and whether he was really
dead and I've always said that we
haven't seen the last of him after all
the seven deadly sins is based on our
theory and legend and the main character
of Arthurian legend is of course King
Arthur I think that this vision that we
see of Arthur at this particular point
in the story constitutes a clear
indication that Arthur will indeed
return in some capacity we have not seen
the last of Arthur because if we had
then this whole scene would be
completely pointless and how about the
fact that we actually had Hawks Bhama
using words for the very first time
while she has done some epic things in
the main series like swallowing Mons
beats hell fire bird attack it was only
in the seven deadly sins movie called
prisoners of the sky that we learned a
lot more about Hawks mama including the
fact that she is actually the legendary
creature known as the mother of chaos
who is the mother of all the creatures
from purgatory while I personally think
that the revelations from the movie are
relevant to the main story there are a
lot of people who consider the prisoners
of the sky movie to be completely
irrelevant to the main storyline however
it is now confirmed that Hawks mama is
capable of communicating with hawk
directly and it is clear that Hawks mama
was conveying some sort of vision or
prophecy about King Arthur the fact that
the balance has been utterly destroyed
probably refers to all the natural
disasters and the fact that malleolus is
still in the mortal plane but what does
soon the king will be born mean is
Arthur about to be reincarnated due to
the power of Excalibur or is he going to
be somehow revived in his original body
if Arthur does somehow come back I can
only assume that he will be a lot more
powerful than he used to be but the
question remains is what kind of role
are revived Arthur would play in the
story personally I never thought that
Arthur truly died I was expecting him to
show up again at some
point however Chapter three one three
seems to confirm that Arthur did indeed
die but he may now be reincarnated or
revived in some way also what's all this
stuff about the mother of chaos being
sleepy is something wrong with her and
if so why is her fatigue somehow related
to the fact that the balance has been
destroyed let me know down in the
comments I am really curious to see what
everyone thinks about the whole Hawkes
mama
and Arthur stuff from this chapter we
then learned that the demon king is
waiting for elizabeth emily otis near
the magic lake of Salsbury
which has the highest concentration of
magic power in britannia the demon king
chose that location because he is trying
to recover his power and fully
assimilate his new vessel as soon as
possible both the demon king and the
sins were injured and badly weakened
during the previous fight so recovering
will be a top priority for the demon
king
we then see a flashback of the moment
that meliodas decided to betray the
demon clan and leave the underworld so
that he could be with elizabeth which
happened during the previous holy war
more than 3,000 years ago meliodas
explains to zell dress that if the holy
war continues one day mel Yodas as the
leader of the ten commandments will find
himself in a situation where he will
have to fight against elizabeth the love
of his life and he can't possibly allow
that to happen
he offers all just a chance to take
gelda the love of his life and come with
him but Zell just refuses to betrayed
the demon clan and he tells meliodas
that he no longer thinks of him as his
brother and that the next time they meet
it will be as enemies back in the
present meliodas remarks to elizabeth at
his proposal to zelgius was actually
foolish because gelda is a vampire and
she could not be expected to permanently
leave the underworld furthermore
melioidosis departure placed a ton of
pressure on zelgius as the substitute
leader of the ten commandments and the
demon Kings other son he must have felt
an immense burden on his shoulders
because zelgius is a man who takes
responsibility and obligations very
seriously and before we move on there is
an important detail from the flashback
of melio descent zelgius that I need to
mention two former members of the ten
commandments Aaron AK and Zeno are
present during the exchange between
malleolus and zelgius and the flashback
ends as zelgius and meliodas realized
that they are being
watched and presumably listened to by
Zeno and Aaron ACK according to the
information that we have so far
when he decided to leave the Ten
Commandments meliodas killed Aaron
Atkins II know it is possible that at
this moment these two Commandments
overheard the conversation and decided
to try and stop meliodas from leaving
which led to him having to kill them it
is also possible that something else
happened we saw that even though he
wasn't happy about his brother leaving
zelgius was prepared to let Mellie Otis
go I'm wondering if the story we got
about Aaron Atkins Eno being killed by
Melly Otis is not completely true
I wonder if Zell drous actually helped
meliodas escape by taking on Aaron
Atkins and on himself or maybe Aaron
Atkins II know didn't fight Melly Otis
at all maybe they actually agreed with
Melly Otis and they decided to leave
with him but zelgius told the demon king
that they were killed so that no one
would go and look for them such a turn
of events would definitely be
interesting because it would mean that
high-ranking demons like Aaron Atkins
Ino might still be alive and out there
somewhere but let me know what you guys
think is the story that we got initially
about Mellie Otis killing Aaron Atkins I
know true or are we about to learn that
something else actually happened finally
we see that the demon king is attempting
to gain full control of his new vessel
by manipulating the consciousness of
zeldron on the inside as zelgius is
consciousness awakens on the inside he
asks his father to give him back his
body and of course we know that zelgius
wants this freedom so that he can go and
rescue gelda but the demon king plays an
incredibly vile but also brilliant trick
on zelgius the demon king appears to
Zell drous in the form of Delta Zell
just refuses to believe that this is the
real gelda at first because meliodas had
told him that he had resealed the real
gelda in edinburgh but the fake gelda
tells him that she is real and she is
appearing to zelgius in spirit form
because she is already dead according to
this gelda she was actually killed by
Melly Otis and the seven deadly sins a
long time ago and meliodas merely told
zelgius d'lai about resealing her so
that he could manipulate him into
helping him become the next demon king
as he struggles to take all of this in
the zelgius get some fake vampire ghosts
oppai action from gelda and we see that
on the outside Elizabeth
have arrived at Lake Salisbury to face
off against the demon king at once again
we are left to wonder whether result
is's consciousness will actually accept
the demon Kings lies but regardless of
whether is all just ultimately sees
through it or not we have to give credit
to the demon king for his devious plan
the two biggest factors that could
potentially inspire zelgius to break the
demon Kings control are his brother
meliodas
and his lover gelda finding gelda is
Zelda's main motivation any of course
cares about his brother malli Otis and
the two brothers have an agreement about
rescuing gelda the demon king
brilliantly kills two birds with one
stone by taking away Zelda's primary
motivation for wanting to be free he
tries to convince algae's that gelda is
already dead and she cannot be saved but
the two of them can be together as souls
or spirits inside zelgius consciousness
on top of that the demon king tries to
convince ljus that it was his brother
meliodas who killed gelda and
manipulated him into thinking that she
was still alive and all this in order to
achieve his own suppose an ambition of
becoming the next demon king if
successful this lie will not only
convince ljus that there is no reason to
fight the demon Kings control but if he
actually begins to believe that meliodas
tricked him and killed gelda he will
likely want to actively help the demon
king fight against malala's in order to
get revenge personally I don't think
that zelgius will fall for this
manipulation in the long run even though
he might slip up and begin to doubt
malleolus at first but I have to say
that everyone who said that the demon
king wasn't a good villain was
completely wrong not only is the demon
king strong and resilient he is also
very deviously clever cold and
calculating which makes him an extremely
interesting and entertaining villain in
my opinion the next chapter is going to
be called merciless salvation and I
can't wait to see where the story will
go from here not only is this new epic
showdown between Melly Otis and the
demon king ramping up in a big way but
we also have the other sins fighting the
Endura
we have that whole crazy scene with a
second or coughing up blood and we have
the mother of chaos and her vision about
King Arthur so much could still happen
in this story and this chapter gave us
even more
questions rather than resolving old ones
so I can definitely see the story
continuing for several arcs at least but
those are my thoughts hit me up with
your thoughts down in the comments don't
forget to check out our sponsor shad
overs it's a ton of fun and free to play
on mobile and PC just click the link in
the description if you enjoy the seven
deadly sins content on this channel you
can leave a like to let me know and if
you're new to anime uproar don't forget
to subscribe and hit that notification
bell as always thank you guys so much
for watching I really appreciate it and
until next time see our space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]